so earlier this year I was informed that
I would be doing a TED talk so I was
excited then I panicked then I was
excited then I panicked and in between
the excitement and the panicking I
started to do my research and my
research primarily consisted of googling
how to give a great TED talk and
interspersed with that I was googling
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie how many of you
know who that is so I was googling her
because I always google her because I'm
just a fan but also because she always
has important and interesting things to
say and the combination of those
searches kept leading me to her talk on
the dangers of a single story on what
happens when we have a solitary lens
through which to understand certain
groups of people and it is the perfect
talk it's the talk that I would have
given if I had been famous first you
know and you know like she's African and
I'm African and she's a feminist and I'm
a feminist and she's a storyteller and
I'm a storyteller so I really felt like
it's my talk
so I decided that I was gonna learn how
to code and then I was gonna hack the
internet and I would take down all the
copies of that talk that existed and
then I would memorize it and then I
would come here and deliver it as if it
was my own speech so that plan was going
really well except the coding part and
then one morning one morning a few
months ago I woke up to the news that
the wife of a certain presidential
candidate had given a speech that
that sounded eerily like a speech given
by one of my other favorite amah and so
I decided that I should probably write
my own TED talk and so that is what I'm
here to do I'm here to talk about my own
observations about storytelling I want
to talk to you about the power stories
of course but I also want to talk about
their limitations particularly for those
of us who are interested in social
justice so since a Deecee gave that talk
seven years ago there has been a boom in
storytelling stories are everywhere and
if there was a danger in the telling of
one tired old tale then I think there's
got to be lots to celebrate about the
flourishing of so many stories and so
many voices stories are the antidote to
bias in fact today if you are
middle-class and connected via the
internet you can download stories at the
touch of a button or the swipe of a
screen you can listen to a podcast about
what it's like to grow up Dalit in
Kolkata you can hear an indigenous man
in Australia talk about the trials and
triumphs of raising his children and
dignity and in Pride stories make us
fall in love the heal rifts and they
bridge divides stories can even make it
easier for us to talk about the deaths
of people in our societies who don't
matter because they make us care right
I'm not so sure and I actually work for
a place called the Center for stories
and my job is to help to tell stories
about the challenge mainstream
narratives about what it means to be
black or Muslim or a refugee or any of
those other categories that we talk
about all the time but I come to this
work after a long history as a social
justice activist and so I'm really
interested in the ways that people talk
about nonfiction storytelling as though
it's about more than entertainment as
though it's about being a catalyst for
social action it's not uncommon to hear
people say that stories make the world
better place increasingly though I worry
that even the most poignant stories
particularly the stories about people
who no one seems to care about can often
get in the way of action towards social
justice now this is not because
storytellers mean any harm quite the
contrary storytellers are often
do-gooders like me and I suspect
yourselves we and the audiences of
storytellers are often deeply
compassionate and empathetic people
still good intentions can have
unintended consequences and so I want to
propose that stories are not as magical
as they seem so three because it's
always got to be three three reasons why
I think that stories don't necessarily
make the world a better place
firstly stories can create an illusion
of solidarity there is nothing like that
feel-good factor you get from listening
to a fantastic story where you feel like
you climbed that mountain right or that
you befriended that death row inmate but
you didn't you haven't done anything
listening as an important but
insufficient step towards social action
secondly I think often we are drawn
towards characters and protagonists who
are likable and human and this makes
sense of course right because if you
like someone then you care about them
but the inverse is also true if you
don't like someone then you don't care
about them and if you don't care about
them you don't have to see yourself as
having a moral obligation to think about
the circumstances that shaped their life
I learned this lesson when I was 14
years old I learned that actually you
don't have to like someone to recognize
their wisdom and you certainly don't
have to like someone to take stand by
their side
so my bike was stolen while I was
writing it which is possible if you're
writing slowly enough which I was so one
minute I'm cutting across this field in
the Nairobi neighborhood where I grew up
and it's like a
very bumpy path and so you know when
you're riding a bike you don't want to
be like you know and so I and so I'm you
know going like this slowly paddling and
all of a sudden I am on the floor I'm on
the ground and I look up and there's
this kid pedaling away in the getaway
vehicle which is my bike and he's about
11 or 12 years old and I'm on the floor
and I'm crying because I saved a lot of
money for that bike and I'm crying and I
stand up and I start screaming instinct
comes steps in and I start screaming me
Weezy Weezy
which means thief in Swahili and out of
the Woodworks all of these people you
know come out and they start to give
chase this is Africa so mob justice like
in action right and I round the corner
and they've captured him they've caught
him the suspect has been apprehended and
they make him give me my bike back and
they also make him apologize again you
know you know typical Africa injustice
right and so they make him say sorry and
so we stand there facing each other and
he looks at me and he says sorry but he
looks at me with this unbridled fury he
is very very angry and it is the first
time that I have been confronted with
someone who doesn't like me simply
because of what I represent he looks at
me with this look as if to say you with
your shiny skin and your bike you're
angry at me so it was a hard lesson that
he didn't like me but you know what he
was right I was a middle-class kid
living in a poor country I had a bike
and he barely had food
sometimes it's the messages that we
don't want to hear the ones that make us
want to crawl out of ourselves
that we need to hear the most for every
lovable storyteller who steals your
heart there are hundreds more whose
voices are slurred and ragged who don't
get to stand up on a stage dressed in
fine clothes like this there are a
million angry boy on a bike stories and
we can't afford to ignore them simply
because we don't like their protagonists
or because that's not the kid that we
would bring home with us from the
orphanage the third reason that I think
that stories don't necessarily make the
world a better place is that too often
we are so invested in the personal
narrative that we forget to look at the
bigger picture and so we applaud someone
when they tell us about their feelings
of shame but we don't necessarily link
that to oppression we nod
understandingly when someone says they
felt small but we don't link that to
discrimination the most important
stories especially for just social
justice are those that do both that are
both personal and allow us to explore
and understand the political but it's
not just about the stories we like
versus the stories we choose to ignore
increasingly we are living in a society
where there are larger forces at play
where stories are actually for many
people beginning to replace the news
yeah we live in a time when we're
witnessing the decline of facts when
emotions rule and analysis it's kind of
boring right where we value what we feel
more than what we actually know a recent
report by the Pew Center on trends in
America indicates that only 10% of young
adults under the age of 30 quote place a
lot of trust in the media now this is
significant it means that storytellers
are gaining trust at precisely the same
moment that many in the media are losing
the confidence in the public this is not
a good thing because while stories are
important and they help us to have
insights in many ways we need the media
for my years as a social justice
activist I know very well that we need
credible facts from media institutions
combined with the powerful voices of
storytellers that's what pushes the
needle forward in terms of social
justice in the final analysis of course
it is justice that makes the world a
better place not stories right and so if
it is justice that we
after then I think we mustn't focus on
the media or on storytellers we must
focus on audiences on anyone who has
ever turned on a radio or listened to a
podcast and that means all of us so a
few concluding thoughts on what
audiences can do to make the world a
better place so firstly the world would
be a better place I think if audiences
were more curious and more skeptical and
asked more questions about the social
context that created those stories that
they loved so much
secondly the world would be a better
place if audiences recognized that
storytelling is intellectual work and I
think it would be important for
audiences to demand more buttons on
their favorite web sites buttons for
example that say if you liked this story
click here to support a cause your
storyteller believes in or click here to
contribute to your storytellers next big
idea often we are committed to the
platforms but not necessarily to the
storyteller themselves and then lastly I
think that audiences can make the world
a better place
by switching off their phones by
stepping away from their screens and
stepping out into the real world beyond
what feels safe Alice Walker has said
look closely at the present you are
constructing it should look like the
future you are dreaming storytellers can
help us to dream but it's up to all of
us to have a plan for justice thank you
[Applause]